[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de cuisiner
la poule au pot avec la poule de Houdan
et pour ça je vous propose de
m'accompagner et de voir tous les locaux
avec qui je travaille au quotidien donc
la première étape c'est d'aller à la
boucherie des arts sur sur oudans pour
récupérer de quoi faire la farce pour la
poule au pot et aussi la pièce du
boucher pour le restaurant pour le
service du jour
salut
[Musique]
salut tout le monde bonjour Jérémy ça va
très bien
le haché alors ça c'est du veau de lait
sous la mer qui vient à s'insérer 100%
naturel
un veau qui a été élevé pendant six mois
donc pour la farce impeccable on
travaille ensemble dans un domaine où il
y a un restaurant bistronomy on essaie
de faire la qualité de produits sachant
qu'on veut qu'on veut que la qualité que
la qualité on travaille 100% de
françaises on travaille avec des
éleveurs de région
de l'Auvergne de Limousin du Lot ce qui
est important avec Jérémy c'est que on
travaille avec l'éleveur de l'éleveur en
jusqu'à la cuisine jusqu'à dans
l'assiette Loïc travaille sur de la bête
entière donc du coup c'est aussi mon but
c'est de travailler les morceaux qu'il a
besoin de distribuer donc quand il me
dit aujourd'hui c'est du faux filet
qu'il faut passer j'ai du faux-filet à
passer le lendemain ça sera peut-être de
l'entrecôte ça sera peut-être de la
honte après mais aujourd'hui l'avantage
c'est d'avoir toujours ce produit
d'exception et c'est ce que nos
consommateurs en tout cas au restaurant
recherchent
pareil une fois un peu de pièces du
boucher je prends un pâté de Houdon
aussi donc le pâté dedans pareil c'est
avec la poule de Houdan qui sont
fabriqués par Stéphane
merci je souhaite une bonne journée les
gars et puis à tout à l'heure si besoin
ou à demain ciao ciao allez bonne
journée bon courage salut salut
[Musique]
maintenant on va se diriger vers notre
maraîcher donc Christophe de qui a la
boutique be free un peu plus haut sur
Houdan
salut salut
[Musique]
normalement il y a tout ce qu'il faut
vérifier si on a oublié
les oignons poireaux parfait c'est top
mais bon c'est bon il y a tout
[Musique]
bon je te remercie pour tout et puis je
te dis je passerai peut-être ça peine si
j'ai besoin ça marche allez ciao bonne
journée à toi bon courage salut
[Musique]
maintenant on part pour la prochaine
étape donc on va vers la le volailler
Julien Lecoq de la ferme le coq
[Musique]